[Music]
when you're watching a television show
or a movie and you see an actor holding
a magazine or book or a letter a lot of
what you're seeing on the screen was
custom-made by people like me
let me see their paperwork
if I've done my job right in creating
that piece of paper the possibilities
are literally endless I mean one single
piece of paper can communicate a huge
amount in telling the audience about the
character or about the scene
it's figuring out how this thing can
best do its job of being a part of the
story my name is Ross Macdonald and I
create paper props for movies and
television when I was a kid I was
obsessed with comics was obsessed with
paper and illustration and really loved
that world that I was reading or seeing
on paper I've done a little bit of
everything for years I worked as a
magazine and newspaper illustrator a
book illustrator that eventually led me
into making props for the last 25 years
I've made tens of thousands of paper
props for close to 50 television shows
and movies my first major motion picture
was babies day out and I was hired
basically as an illustrator to
illustrate a Pho 1930s children's book
I've done literally tens of thousands of
props for all five seasons Boardwalk
Empire I did the Pawnee charter for an
episode of Parks and Recreation for joy
I did all of the patents for the mops
that we see played I did you Nick
secrets socialite he was played for The
Wizard of lies
I've designed everything from passports
and maps and travel documents wanted
posters government forms FBI reports
psychiatric files agent identification
folders anything that's made of paper I
made at one time or another part of what
you need to figure out when you're
making a paper prop is the backstory of
the piece of paper you don't just take a
new book and slosh brown ink on to make
it look old you got to figure out how it
got worn how it got dirty the scene
might involve an actor reading three
lines out of a letter but you have to
figure out how old is it what kind of
paper is it made out of how was the
paper made should it be made with carbon
paper should it be on onion skin some
guy gonna pull out a ruffled piece of
paper from his pocket or is he gonna
pull it out of a file folder what color
paper should it be should it be yellow
should it be white should it be ivory
colored who's signing it what does their
handwriting look like what kind of ink
are they using when they write it what
kind of pen are they using and then
because no letter is ever three lines
you have to write the rest of the copy
in the letter depending on what I'm
making a project can take you know a day
an hour weeks months every page is
filled out every book has text on it
pictures every paper in the file folder
is is a real document that's all filled
out and created for example for the Book
of Secrets they said just come up with
secrets so I said okay well let's do
Roswell let's do the Kennedy
assassination let's do all these crazy
conspiracy theory things then there was
the research into those specific things
so you have to find all that figure out
how to recreate it convincingly it was a
huge undertaking it took about four
months to really build that prop and
it's just communicated in a split second
in the scene have you seen the evening
paper I have here pieces of paper
there's so many amazing things that
start off with a piece of paper and the
props that I'm making are all part of
that sometimes when they go to the
theater I'm so excited I'm almost
shaking and it's not because I want to
see the driver's license I made from one
of the actors it's because I I did a
tiny bit of work on that movie and it's
that's very exciting to me in the end
you've produced this thing which you
know you've done your best job of
nailing getting absolutely right and you
know sometimes I'm just like wow you see
something like that in the final product
and realize that this thing you've
worked on is this huge moment in the
story that can be just really really a
great family
[Music]